i just made a new mug that says [ __ ]
good all right next one wait this
reminds me of something since she
mentioned how old she i didn't even this
isn't on my list of things to bring up
but i want to bring it up because i know
we're talking about old people now alex
you can get back in on the conversation
about this i want to talk about cable
cable versus no streaming i'll talk to
apps no i have an argument i want this
argument to be cleared up with everyone
that's sitting in the back that's even
younger than i am because
i was talking
every morning i go get coffee with my
parents
um
and their friends who are all the same
age as them
right 60 and over
yes dad
are you all 60 and over you want to talk
about cable yeah
no i'm bored for a minute and i know you
had a close-up of me being bored
i could tell i saw the camera zoom in is
this a boring conversation no i really
don't even get nobody wants to hey wait
wait wait wait what uh daniel no
can we get a shot for shot remake of the
great dictator in production starring
the map maker who is recently a csi guy
as the lead now there's a great question
the [ __ ] is he talking about no it was
the one before that go go the one that
you had why are you changing them i
really do want to keep talking about it
it's okay so you're having coffee with
old people go ahead and she wants to
know and i was having an argument about
going somewhere and having cable or
streaming and i said there's no need for
cable anymore and then they were all
arguing that they refused to stay
anywhere that didn't have cable right
because we don't know how to use youtube
tv
but you're telling mom said that she
stayed somewhere once
that only had streaming leave it there
and it's not real tv because she tried
to watch an id
oh my god this is so annoying but it's
not interesting i'm being honest with
you i'm just going to be honest with you
it's not a good question nobody's saying
get in here you got to hear this podcast
he's talking she's talking about cable
versus i think it'll lead to arguments
in i'm arguing with you stop talking
about this anyway
you didn't start at the top i always
like to say the person's name why do you
keep you have to move it because
otherwise we have to blur their email
that's why i'm scooting down yeah yeah
it's a lot more okay so this is
afterwards i'll talk about tell me who
it's from then you tell me who it's from
max
magdalene zuckerberg this i want to
thank you howie for being so transparent
on your podcast people don't realize
unless they see me in person i am
see-through
i have to i have anxiety and it got
worse in the pandemic pandemic before
the pandemic i had a lot of diversions
as you said i retired during the
pandemic
and now my anxiety and depression has
gotten worse why am i having trouble
saying pandemic
you don't want to talk to me
no i'm over you
this is now we're pissed at each other
so that's good we're getting a family
dynamic they usually don't can
i too am in therapy i listen to your
podcast each week thanks for the love
you told me before this show to plan
stuff and what we're going to talk about
and you came up and the brilliance that
you came up with was let's talk about
cable versus streaming
no but you're so rude i'm not rude i'm
being honest with you it's not an
interesting topic i'll talk okay let's
talk about it no it's not jeremy will
decide after whether it'll be edited out
go ahead i brought up like four things
like the dominoes thing where we can
call people you're like that's old and
then like moved on and then i brought it
up but having having a pizza place
called another pizza place
to try it i to try it you know how many
times i've heard it
the chinese place calling the other
chinese food place
i used to also put your mom's friends on
with other friends so then do it i
haven't heard it and i think it's funny
i'm not agreeing but you're just
knocking okay whatever no i'm not not do
you no you do this don't go ahead by
yourself no yeah no yeah no
we're not getting along
this is not funny it's not even good
i told you to prepare stuff i did do you
want to hear my list the list already
you told me you didn't want to do where
uh alex and i tell truths from our
childhood i don't need that you're
knocking everything that i came up with
not enjoying it
let's just sit quietly and enjoy
ourselves alex
alex oh he's going to get more cheese
are you going to get cheese
are you coming in he wants to come in
okay
he wants to say something
for anyone that didn't know
uh
lou is gonna be at the tropicana
from march 28 to april
third and on the first
he's going to be giving away yes one
billion dollars
you know what's funny
not everybody is like a fan and maybe
this is the first one they're ever
seeing
let's just argue yeah it's just arguing
and then a non-sequitur about uh
lose dates that's hysterical alex that's
really funny for those that don't know
lou uh plugs his trumpet candidate ad
nauseam we were doing one just gonna be
a family show and then my son who i
asked before would you want to be anyone
no no don't ask me his
sister tried to engage him in a
conversation he goes no i need string
cheese and now
at the most we finally hooked on to
something that we were really talking
about that everybody was really
interested in we finally
[Laughter]
talked about cable versus streaming and
he came in and plugged lucho
[Music]
you